I find her hi I'm Johnny hi everyone I'm
Billy hi I'm Alyssa when I'm it's his
shot and we're gonna be answering your
questions
is there a Clown College while I went
and I graduated have you been I have and
I have a degree as well there's a bunch
in Europe who Sasha Baron Cohen came out
of him it's very like Clown College it's
like fancy and it's very theatrical it's
if you go to Clown College is it hard to
make people laugh boy is it ever I don't
want to toot my own horn but I find it
easy to make people think I'm delightful
I love just acting like an idiot and I
feel like whenever I am myself my true
authentic self I am the most funny so
that's just what I deliver as my problem
I find personally my opinion it's not
that easy to meet people that have are
you done
clowns embrace being just a dumb dumb
stupid and what is solving it falling is
funny yeah it's real funny and when I
see someone fall you bet your bottom
dollar know that yeah if I fall I want
people to laugh yeah my parents when
they first found out that I wanted to be
a clown were devastated my mom like was
a cloud which is sounds like a fake
story um but so yeah she was like yes
you know she like taking this seriously
she's like I need to teach you
everything I know about balloons my
mom's a balloon expert I got written up
at an office job for be too loud and
distracted like of not keeping my inside
feelings inside and just I just don't
alert stuff out you know and so I think
we saw it I think my father's first
reaction was why Lord why you get a
couple of reactions you either get
you know or you get the weirdest thing
is sometimes when you're working as a
clown you have to drive into work you
have to arrive fully made up in costume
so you're driving across Hollywood and
you look like this and someone looks at
you in the other car and you know
they're like freaked out or other times
you're like oh yeah happy whoo
so it's they hate you or they love you
that's Hollywood for me I've got a lead
foot so it's always I hate me and a big
old middle finger being thrown up there
and for middle fingers for children
watching that that means he's number one
yes there are some clowns that are sad
but some of us are delightful I mean I
can't be for you I said well if we're
going back to commedia dell'arte three
or four hundred years ago they were here
to basically be the Joker's to make the
King laugh so that no one's heads would
be cut off why do clouds exist
I think clowns exist originally for
children until Stephen King made it
horrible for all of us if you don't make
me laugh you'll die but that's all I
felt growing up I think that clowns are
God's gift to earth
[Applause]
just sayin here
why do clowns creep us out it's rude I
don't live in a sewer do you live in a
sewer no no the red nose you symbolize
drunkenness that's what all right nose
comes from yeah so I think maybe it's
the symbol of somebody who's like kind
of like I don't know what to expect from
them off their rockers yeah sweets that
definitely Pennywise has given us clowns
a bad name killing you and that you're
scared of the extreme you think I don't
know yes I am they should Jana McDonald
I have not personally that's cool I have
a sixth toe I should you can make good
money yeah that's what a photocopier is
for people don't realize how expensive
it is to be a client like the makeup
costs a lot of money the shoes cost like
a good pair of clown shoes cost up to
$1,000 King clowns have facial hair yeah
why not
however in classic clown makeup they do
shave and then they paint the beard on
so for the hobo do what you want loans
and clowns have beards yes and they can
draw them on to if they want to I just
shaved my goatee to do this art clowns
and jesters this thing is a broad I
don't say no okay but yeah our clowns
and gestures the same gesture to me is
more just like the fool I feel like
they're in the same wheelhouse they've
got the same common goals which is to
make the audience laugh but it's also
the job of the gesture and the clown to
lower themselves to Ray
the audience up so yes a court jester is
there to make rich people laugh a clown
is to make the children of the world
Wow I think if anything it's not
necessarily like being a clown that
would turn people off but it's like if I
don't know how to turn off my cloud yeah
it's not something that I lead into when
I'm starting to date however it is a
pretty unique amazing quality about me
and who doesn't want to date the funny
guy right funny is money and funny is
also dateable and if you don't think so
swipe left so I think just a final kind
of wrap up as you can see us clowns were
just like everybody else I hope if
people take away one thing it's that the
vast majority of clowns are not scary
and assuming that all of us are the like
is assuming that other people that you
don't know anything about are all alike
glad they're real people I agree yeah
and I feel like we're just real people
trying to make the world a little less
sad and that's a good thing and we want
to help make you a little less sad we're
doing this because it is our passion it
is what drives us to wear this red nose
and look ridiculous it is all for your
enjoyment
[Music]